- Uh, what makes me laugh?
- Funny stuff.
- Uh, fart jokes make me laugh.
(upbeat music)
- People, other people.
We like laughing at other people.
- Other people's despair.
- People laugh at me,
and people laugh with him.
- (laughs) Definitely, Malory.
- Yes.
- Do you think you're funnier than me?
- I never thought about it.
- Let's not like drive this
wedge between us right now.
Like we're both funny, period.
- You're so serious.
Stop.
- Oh my God.
(exhales forcefully)
- I have no idea what I'm gonna do.
(clucks like a chicken)
- You're not gonna laugh?
This really hurts me.
(laughs)
- Ahhhh!
Did it.
- Knock, knock.
- Who's there?
- Amos.
- Amos who?
- A mosquito.
(laughs)
Hey.
- You know when you like
try to fight a fart?
Ohh, that's it.
(laughs)
- Pa, pa, pa peanut.
(vibrating voice)
- Peanut (laughs)
Peanut.
- Pudding.
Pudding?
Pudding.
Pudding ah!
(laughs) I can't!
(blows out)
- (laughs) I can't!
You dance like that when
we exercise together.
(snorts and laughs)
- God, you look like an idiot.
(laughs)
I love it, you're so cute.
- I think I played into your weaknesses,
knowing how you would react.
- I'd say the hardest part
is not making any sound.
I feel like my strength in comedy
is like words and wordplay.
- Usually, we laugh like immediately
or even before we start telling a joke.
- I mean, I was basically just laughing
to make him feel better.
So I don't think that's fair.
- The hardest part was being unprepared.
- I feel like I can be a funny person,
but it's really hard to be
funny without any kind of like--
- Someone to talk to.
[Guy] stimulant.
- It's probably the hardest
day I've had in a while.
(laughs)
(upbeat music)